so we went from this is going to be a
boom time to we could be looking at a
bear market really really fast so joe
biden yesterday he came out and he spoke
to the press and then of course the
press were ushered out without being
able to ask any serious questions of him
well on their way out the press do what
they usually do which is they start
yelling questions to the president of
the united states in the hopes that he
responds and peter ducey caught a fish
right he threw his line in the water and
he caught a fish this time joe biden did
respond to him but it was on a hot mic
and here's what it sounded like
that's a great asset
more inflation
what a stupid song
[Music]
okay so
the actual question that ducey asked was
do you think inflation is a political
liability in the midterms and biden
responded it's a great asset more
inflation what a stupid son of a
and he said that about about
peter ducey so
a few things here that are kind of
hilarious first of all i don't care very
much about presidents saying things that
we all say about one another except they
happen to get caught on a mic as
somebody who's on a mic half of the day
i'm sure that there's audio of me saying
things on a hot mic that i really
wouldn't want to be public so i really
don't care too much about this however
the hypocrisy of the media here is
astonishing astonishing because you'll
remember that donald trump once called a
reporter
a son of a right at a rally this
is in september of 2017. and chris hayes
posted today the president called
american citizens to express their
political views sons of
and then yesterday after this happened
with peter ducey he tweeted literal lol
or how about brian stelter from cnn the
watchdog of the media he said calling a
journalist a son of a it was wrong
when trump was just a candidate it's
even worse now that he's president
because he did it again in march of
2018. hey so what what did he have to
say yesterday quote at the end of a
biden photo op when reporters shouted
queues hoping he'd respond fox's peter
ducey asked do you think inflation is a
political liability in the midterms
biden deadpan it's a great asset more
inflation what a stupid son of a
so it was totally fine with brian
stelzer this time around
meanwhile
you'll recall that in 2020 donald trump
called somebody a name and here is joe
biden's tweet trump deflects legitimate
questions with attacks he bullies
members of the press instead of taking
responsibility for his failures his
efforts to undermine public confidence
in the integrity of reporting violate
our core values and threaten our very
system of government it was all pearl
clutching all the way down when it was
trump but when it's biden it's just a
genial old fellow who sometimes gets a
little bit cadrery you know nbc's kelly
o'donnell who by the way is the incoming
president of the white house
correspondents association she tweet she
said yesterday on the air about biden
quote he does not like when questions
are asked about a subject other than the
planned event
oh so it's okay now got it because it
was joe biden says okay remember joe
biden said just a couple of months ago
that he would fire anybody who's
disrespectful to other reporters that
was after one of his one of his press
secretaries tj ducklow called up a
reporter and started yelling at her so
here was biden just a few months back
i'm not joking when i say this
if you're ever working with me and i
hear you treat another colleague with
disrespect
talk down to someone
i promise you i will fire you on the
spot
well sadly we cannot fire him on the
spot that is too bad apparently biden
did call peter ducey on monday evening
and ducey said after years of clips of
the president and me mixing it up on the
campaign trail and during the transition
and here at the white house within about
an hour of that exchange he caught my
cell phone he said it's nothing personal
pal we went back and forth and we were
talking about just kind of moving
forward i made sure to tell them i'm
always going to try to ask something
different than what everybody else is
asking and he said you got to and that's
a quote from the president so i'll keep
doing it
and um when asked if biden actually
apologized ducey said he cleared the
error and i appreciated it we had a nice
call
and uh that is not an apology so joe
biden did not in fact call to apologize
for calling peter ducey a son of a
he just said it's nothing personal by
the way it did make it into the white
house transcript which is one of the
great transcripts he had in in american
history that is right there in the white
house transfer it's like george
washington or abraham lincoln basically
president biden now again what this
comes back to is a basic perception of
politics that the left has just gotten
wrong and many on the right got it wrong
too which is that donald trump was the
murderer of american politics not the
coroner i've said this a thousand times
donald trump was elected president
because he stumbled upon the body of
american politics it was still warm and
there's a knife directly in its back and
then he crouched over it and looked at
the knife in the back and everybody went
he did it it was him he must have
murdered politics nope it was like this
before it'll be like this afterward
again joe biden is not all that
different from donald trump
he's
just more used to washington dc
the belief that donald trump was a
difference in kind in terms of being
rude and nasty to people is ridiculous
and barack obama was a pretty prickly
fellow and joe biden has been routinely
prickly with people for years you
remember that on the campaign trail he
literally called one of his constituents
fat
and there's a bernie sanders supporter
who is asking him questions he goes look
fat you're never gonna have a push-up
conscious right now fat man you want to
do it fat guy it's just he's a
ridiculous person
but again it's the media's double
standard here that is truly astonishing
when joe biden does it it is perfectly
appropriate and totally cool and when it
is anybody else who is republican then
it's because they're bad and mean and
it's the death of democracy and
democracy is at stake and the free press
is about to be trampled upon
it's amazing how many reporters made a
mint off of the period in which the free
press was supposedly in existential
danger
i know what you're thinking it's time to
binge some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right you should but first like
and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video